Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Dr. Erblän ist mein Name. Ich bin zuständiger Ärztin heute für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, klar. Natürlich. Habt doch mehr hilft jemand.
Okay. Ich möchte zuerst ein paar Personen bezogene Fragen stellen.
Ich möchte Sie das Anamnese-Gespräch überführen.
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Was heißt das?
Ich heiße Ingel Covaman.
Ingel, ich heiße mit E.
Mit E, wie E-Mail.
Ja, Ingel Covaman.
Covaman mit V.
V, Covaman. Okay.
Ein Doppel an am Ende?
Ja.
Okay.
So, Frau Covaman, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 39.
39.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8.07.84.
84. Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Covaman?
1.73.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit, wissen Sie?
Na so rund 75 kg.
75 kg. Okay.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Frau Covaman, was für Sie zu uns, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, also ich habe seit gestern Abend so heftige Kopfschmerzen.
Und zwar, also ganz, ganz krass auf der linken Seite.
Und ich kann überhaupt nicht gut gucken.
Und mir ist so schlecht, ich musste mich mehrfach übergeben.
Und also es sind solche Schmerzen,
die ich überhaupt noch nie erlebt habe.
Und jetzt muss ich Ihnen sagen, ich habe wirklich ein bisschen Angst.
Deswegen bin ich auch direkt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay.
Wissen Sie, meine Mutter ist an einem Hirntumor gestorben.
Und jetzt habe ich mit einmal solche Panik,
dass das vielleicht auch ein Hirntumor ist.
Und mir ist es schlecht.
Und ich habe solche Kopfschmerzen.
Ich bin völlig erschöpft.
Ich verstehe, Herr Covaman, Sie sind sehr gut.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Frau Covaman.
Sie haben gut gemacht, zu uns gekommen sind.
Ich verstehe, diese Kopfschmerzen sind auch erst einmal aufgetreten.
Ja, ich habe so etwas noch nie gehabt.
Und das ist so, ja, am Anfang habe ich das gemerkt,
dass irgendwas komisch war,
dass ich nicht richtig gucken konnte.
Und mit einmal fing das an.
Und ich kann mich überhaupt gar nicht wieder einkriegen.
Es sind solche Schmerzen.
Und mir ist so schlecht.
Und ich habe mich jetzt von dem Nachbarn her bringen lassen.
Ich konnte überhaupt nicht Auto fahren oder so.
Weil ich so schwach bin und weil mir so schlecht ist.
Und weil ich diese rasenden Kopfschmerzen habe.
Okay.
Ja, so rasenden Kopfschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen, Frau Covaman?
Ja, das hat heute Nacht angefangen.
Davon bin ich auch aufgewacht.
Also am Abend hatte ich schon diese komischen Sehstörungen.
Ich dachte, ich gehe mal früh ins Bett.
Und dann fing das mit einmal an, dass ich diese Schmerzen hatte.
Ich musste auch gleich in der Nacht.
Bin ich schon einmal aufs Toilette gegangen und musste mich übergeben.
Und wie viele Mal haben Sie erbrochen?
Da kam gar nichts mehr.
Aber ich hatte mal so dieses Gefühl, ich muss so rühren.
Aber drei, vier Mal war das bestimmt.
Okay.
Aber es kam nichts.
Ja, erst war natürlich noch ein bisschen was da von meinem Abendessen.
Und dann war aber als der Magen leer war, musste ich mich immer noch so.
Hatte ich immer noch das Gefühl, ich müsste brechen.
Und dann kam nur noch so bitteres Zeug.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Frau Covaman, sind die Stahl in die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass das sich so durch den Kopf bohrt.
Und dass das Auge auch weh tut und dass das so hinten ein bisschen in den Nacken reinstrahlt.
Aber Sie haben keine Schmerzen am Hals, ja?
Nein, Halsschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sind die Schmerzen nur rasende oder auch bohrende, pulsierende?
Ja, pulsierend ist gut, das beschreibt das gut und bohrend, ja, das ist ...
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder gehen sie wieder weg?
Nein, sie sind ständig da.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkala, wobei ein sehr leid 10 unerträgliches Schmerzen entspricht?
Also, ich weiß ja nicht, was noch mehr kommen kann, aber bei 7 oder 8 sind die bestimmt.
Sursat 7 oder 8 Jahre.
Frau Covaman, können Sie diese Schmerzen am Ende des Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie Schmerzmittel?
Ja, ich habe ja schon etwas genommen, aber das hilft ja alles.
Was so ein bisschen hilft, wenn ich zwischendurch die Augen zu mag,
kann so schlecht ins Licht gucken und insofern können wir ruhig weiterreden.
Ich mache dann vielleicht zwischendurch die Augen zu.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe, vielen Dank.
Was haben Sie eingenommen dagegen?
Ja, ich hatte Aspirin da und da habe ich etwas genommen.
Ich habe zweimal 500 eingenommen, aber das hat nicht viel gebracht.
Aspirin 500?
Zwei Mal, okay.
Ja, und dann musste ich mich ja auch gleich wieder übergeben und hilf ja auch die beste Tablette nix.
Ich verstehe, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten oder langsam?
Nein, ich würde sagen, die sind ganz plötzlich gekommen.
Sind die Ihnen an irgendwelche Auslöser dafür aufgefallen?
Ja, das war ein total hektischer Tag.
Es war total stressig, ich bin allein erzielt, habe drei Kinder zu Hause und habe meine Arbeit.
Bis zum Schluss war da viel Betrieb.
Dann haben die Kinder irgendwie nicht richtig ausgelastet, die haben ja Ferien und dann waren die gar nicht in der Schule heute.
Und dann haben sie nur Quatsch gemacht und waren so laut, als ich nach Hause kam.
Und haben überhaupt gar keine Ruhe gegeben und wollten nicht schlafen gehen.
Ja, da war schon Stress.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Sehr hektische Tage.
Ist Ihnen, ja, ergibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ist Ihnen das aufgefallen?
Ja, also als es dann ruhig war, hatte ich das Gefühl, als die Kinder endlich im Bett waren und Ruhe war,
hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen besser geht und dass ich es besser aushalten kann.
Aber wenn der Geschrei war oder auch wenn der helles Licht war, das konnte ich überhaupt nicht vertragen.
Da wurde es schlechter.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Im Dunkeln liegen war eigentlich das angenehmste dann noch.
Da waren die Schmerzen, haben wir weiter gebohrt, aber ich hatte irgendwie das Gefühl, ich kann es besser ertragen.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Frau Koppermann, Sie haben gesagt, dass am Anfang Sie können nicht ganz genau gucken.
Meinen Sie, sehr störmgen oder gibt es Schmerz während der Augenbewegung?
Nein, also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich kein richtiges Blickfeld mehr habe.
Wie lange dauert das?
Oh, vielleicht zwei, am Abend, vielleicht so 20 Minuten oder so, vierte Stunde?
Okay, können Sie einfach Ihren Kopf nach oder links drehen?
Also gibt es Schmerz oder nach vorne folgen?
Nein, das tut nicht weh.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wie fühlen Sie sich, Sie haben gesagt erschöpft und gibt es Fieber?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht fieberig.
Okay, und fühlen Sie sich auch, gibt es Taubheitgefühl am Arm oder irgendwelche ihren Körper?
Ja, also tatsächlich hat das hier in der rechten Hand, hatte ich so ein Trübelgefühl.
Rechter Hand?
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden früher auch oder sind Sie?
Nein, ich kenne so etwas gar nicht, deswegen bin ich ja auch sofort zu Ihnen gekommen,
weil ich wirklich richtig Angst habe, dass irgendetwas mit dem Kopf los ist.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Frau Koperman, leiden Sie unter Atemnot oder schwindelig?
Nein, schwindelig eigentlich ist mir nicht, es sind nur diese Kopfschmerzen,
ich habe nicht dabei, nein, und Luftschrullen kann ich auch gut.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Herzstrasen oder Herzsturfen?
Also am Anfang hatte ich so das Gefühl, dass es los ging,
dass ich so ein bisschen mehr Herzklopfen habe, aber vielleicht auch weil ich Panik hatte, ne?
Ja, genau, wahrscheinlich, vielleicht.
Okay, ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen, Ihre Alte Mannzustand stellen, Frau Koperman.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit zurzeit? Ich glaube nicht gut, aber normalerweise bin ich ein guter Esser,
aber heute braucht man da nicht mehr dran zu denken.
Okay, hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit merklich verändert?
Nee, das ist immer gleich.
So, wie ist Ihr Schlaf? Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Ja, also wenn es sehr stressig ist, kann ich manchmal schlecht einschlafen oder wach nachts auf
und habe dann irgendwie, komme nicht wieder in den Schlaf,
aber normalerweise würde ich sagen schlafe ich ganz gut,
aber heute Nacht habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Ja, ja, verständlich, genau. Aber nehmen Sie etwas gegen Schlafprobleme?
Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie Stress haben, nicht.
Nein, also ich manchmal trinke ich abends noch ein Glas Wein, um runterzukommen oder so,
aber normalerweise, also das ist nicht so oft, dass das passiert.
Okay, ich verstehe, gut. Und haben Sie Probleme mit Stullgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, also zum Glück nicht, nein.
Okay, gut, ja.
Frau Koffermann, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie an irgendein Fall schon ein bisschen kranker als Zuckerkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Mein Gott, das will ich in meinem Alter, nein, nein. Also eigentlich bin ich ganz gesund.
Das Einzige, was ich mal hatte, das ist aber jetzt schon 3, 4 Jahre,
hey, ich glaube das war nach kurz nach der Geburt des letzten Kindes,
dass ich mal eine Thrombose hatte, aber die war auch nicht...
Wo sind die Thrombose?
Im Bein.
Im Weichernbein?
Im rechten Bein.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich halt Heparin bekommen und habe einen Kompressionsstrumpf getragen
und dann hat man danach geguckt und war alles in Ordnung
und es war auch jetzt nicht so, dass da irgendwie eine Gerinnungsstörung war oder so.
Okay, waren Sie damals stationär behandelt?
Nein, nein, das ist nur ambulant.
Nur ambulant, okay, ich verstehe.
Nach dem Heparin-Therapie, haben Sie auch andere...
Ja, ein halbes Jahr lang habe ich so ein Gerinnungshämmer dann genommen.
Wie Marko?
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Marko war, aber ich glaube das war irgendwie ein neues...
Rivalox, oder?
Ja, sowas war das glaube ich, ja.
Okay.
Und dann, als dann alles gut war, konnte man das wieder absetzen.
Freut mich, brauche ich auch immer.
Ja.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig Kontrolle wegen dieser Probleme?
Ja, also ich gehe zum Haushalts, wenn ich irgendetwas habe
und ich gehe halt regelmäßig zum Gynäkologen,
aber jetzt wegen des Beines bin ich jetzt nicht wieder hingegangen.
Okay.
Aber ich habe auch da jetzt keine Beschwerden.
Ach, sehr gut.
Und wenn ich eine längere Reise mache,
was weiß ich, dann hole ich halt brav meine Kompressionsstrumpfe wieder raus.
Ja, ja, das ist sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig?
Nein, zurzeit, also ich habe jetzt nur das aus Pirin eingenommen wegen der Kompetenzen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind allein als Sie herrschen.
Ja.
Haben Sie Freunde oder so, nehmen Sie auch Pille?
Ach so, nicht befreit, ist da keine Veranlassung dazu?
Okay. Sie nehmen keine Pille, ja?
Nein, keine Verhütung.
Okay, verstehe.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert, Frau Kopanat?
Nein, noch nie.
Ja, alle drei Kinder sind entbündung.
Sind ganz normal erkunden, ja.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen irgendwelche Medikamente oder Stoffe?
Ist mir nichts bekannt.
Also bisher ist noch nichts aufgefallen.
Also, wenn ich alles womit ich zu tun habe, kann ich gut vertragen.
Okay, alles klar.
Und Sie haben keine Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, nein.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt, ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Gewohnheit.
Rachen Sie Frau Kopanat?
Brauchen, nein, raufen so recht.
Freuchen, dann.
Sie haben gesagt, manchmal Sie trinken ein Glas Wein am Abend, ja?
Ja.
Und treiben Sie sich porträtig einmäßig Frau Kopanat?
Ja, da komme ich nicht so sehr viel dazu.
Ich fahre am Wochenende oft mal mit dem Fahrrad rum
und manchmal, also mit den Kindern gehe ich jetzt im Sommer schwimmen,
aber dass ich jetzt richtig regelmäßig sportreiten würde,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Aber wenn es darauf ankommt, kann ich ein bisschen losmachen.
Also ich kann Fahrrad fahren und ich kann schwimmen.
Und wenn es dann soweit ist, dann bin ich auch ganz fit.
Was zusammen schwimmen, ist sehr gut, ja, als Familie.
Dann, Sie haben drei Kinder, sind Sie alle gesund?
Ja, zum Glück sind die alle.
Gott sei Dank.
Und was machen Sie beruflich Frau Kopanat?
Ich arbeite als Marklerin.
Marklerin, ja.
Aber ich bin angestellt, also ich habe keine eigene Firma,
aber trotzdem ist es manchmal ziemlich stressig.
Ja, ich verstehe aber, angestellt zu sein, auch sehr gut, ja.
Ja, dadurch kann ich nicht Vollzeit arbeiten, ne?
Ja, genau, mit Kindern, ja, nicht einfach.
Ich verstehe. Wie ist die Impfstatus, Frau Kopanat?
Weil ich bin natürlich gegen Corona geimpft
und seit der Zeit auch alles, was so an Kinderkrankheiten
alles abgeimpft, ja.
Okay, sehr gut.
Waren Sie in den letzten drei Monaten im Ausland?
Ja, warten Sie mal, in den Osterferien waren wir auf Mallorca.
Wie lange ist das her, ja, das ist so genau drei Monate her.
Ja, ich war gut.
Ja, ich möchte etwas wissen über Ihre Familiengeschichte, Frau Kopanat.
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Mutter an Hirn-Tümur-Perstorben ist.
Ja, deswegen habe ich jetzt solche Angst, wissen Sie,
wenn ihr versteht, was es ist, da trich man gleich Panik.
Ja, wie alt war sie, als sie per Storben ist?
Sie war 66.
Ist gut, mir geht es sehr leid, Frau Kopanat.
Wie ist der Vater Gesundheitszustand?
Ja, der liebt auch nicht mehr. Der war dann ein hohen Alter,
also er war deutlich älter und er hatte da eine Demenz
und letztendlich, wir wissen nicht, was sonst war,
aber er ist dann verstorben.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Ich bin mit dem Geschick durch Frau Kopanat.
Ich möchte kleine Zusammenfassungen machen,
wenn ich etwas verstanden habe oder vergessen.
Korrigieren Sie mich bitte, okay?
Sie haben gestern Abend heftige linksseitige Kopfschmerzen.
Am Anfang haben Sie sehr Störungen auf
und es dauert ungefähr 20 Minuten.
Sie sind empfindlich gegen Lärm und heller Licht.
Sie denken an Stress als Auslöser für die Schmerzen.
Können Sie mir vorstellen, Ja.
Die Schmerzintensität sind bei 7, 8 von 10.
Die Schmerzcharakter sind rasend pulsierend und bohrend.
Sie haben Übelkeit und 3-4 Mal haben sie schon übergeben.
Sie haben 2 Mal 500 Milligramm Aspirin angenommen.
Aber die Tablette hat ihnen nichts geholfen.
Das stimmt ja.
Sie mussten übergeben, deswegen vielleicht.
Sie haben am Anfang auch Herzstrasse,
aber sie denken wegen Panik vielleicht.
Später zurzeit haben Sie keine Herzrasen.
Genau.
Sie haben auch recht Hande krippen.
Sie haben Kraftlosigkeit.
Können Sie etwas greifen?
Ich glaube, in dem Moment war das nicht so gut.
Ich habe fast mein Wasserglas umgeworfen.
Das erinnere ich noch.
Es war so richtig sicher, dass es nicht mit der Hand war.
Es fühlte sich unangenehm mit dem Kribbeln an.
Es gibt aber keine Zittern, oder?
Nein.
Das ist alles.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzutun?
Sie haben alles aufgespielt.
Ich möchte nur noch wissen, was man dagegen tun kann.
Was die Ursache ist.
Wie man herausfinden kann, dass das kein Gehirntumor ist.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Ich bin froh, dass Sie positiv bleiben.
Sie haben viele verschiedene Ursachen aufgetreten.
Sie denken nicht von Schlimmsten, sondern von Schlimmsten.
Sie sind bei uns gut aufgehoben.
Wir werden alles, um Sie wieder gesund zu werden.
Das ist gut.
Meine Kinder brauchen mich.
Ja, absolut.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Ich habe auch drei Kinder.
Frau Koperman, Sie bekommen eine Infusion von uns.
Für diese Schmerzen.
Legen Sie sich bitte.
Ich werde Sie erst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde auch eine Schädel-Kanzpintomografie veranlasst.
Dann weiß man, ob das nicht schlimm ist.
Ja, genau.
Das ist gut.
Ich komme gleich.
Ja, danke.
Die Zeit ist vorbei.
Mehr als fünf Minuten.
Ja.
Danke.
Haben Sie sich direkt oder indirekt am Kopf verletzt?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht gestoßen.
Ich hatte keinen Unfall, keinen Fahrradunfall oder so etwas im Helm.
Nein, keine Verletzung.
Messen Sie regern, wie sich ihr dann blutdruck?
Nein, ich habe keinen hohen Blutdruck.
Liste Frage.
Trinken Sie aus reichen Flüssigkeit?
Eigentlich bin ich jemand, der ziemlich viel trinkt.
Wenn Patrianten trinken müssen,
haben Sie diese Frage durst kommen?
Ach so.
Ich trink eigentlich mehr aus Vernunft, weil man sagt, dass das gut ist.
Aber dass ich jetzt starten durst habe, kann ich nicht sagen.
Frau Koelman, könnten Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Wo die Schmerzen am stärksten sind?
Oder wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen sind in der linken Kopfhälfte.
Und sie sind bohrend.
Ich habe das Gefühl, man dreht eine große Schraube in meinen Kopf.
Eine Seite oder beide Seite?
Die linke Seite.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
War Ihnen früher schwarz vor Augen?
Oder waren Sie unmächtig?
Unmächtig war ich nicht.
Mir war auch nicht schwarz vor Augen,
sondern ich hatte nur dieses Gefühl,
dass das Gesichtshält eingeschränkt ist.
Ich möchte das auch fragen.
Fliegen Sie vor den Augen?
Ach so.
Fliegen Sie hin und her, schwimmen Sie?
Das hatte ich nicht.
Es war nur so Schatten.
Vielen Dank.
Vor der Anfall haben Sie irgendfals ein Geräusch.
Ein Geräusch?
Ja, ein Geräusch.
Oder eine Kettokokonäne?
Was bedeutet?
Ein komischer Geräusch.
Vor dem Schmelzen.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Sind Sie wäkerfühlig?
Wetterfühlig.
Das muss schon sehr extrem sein, dass ich das merke.
Ich war mal im Urlaub.
Da war Föhnwetter in den Alpen.
Da habe ich gemerkt, dass es Kopfschmerzen hatte.
Aber hier bei unserem Wetter merke ich nichts.
War Herr Kaufmann, haben Sie Gangstörung?
Gangstörung?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich bin aber nicht viel rumgelaufen,
weil ich solche Kopfschmerzen habe.
Haben Sie gleichzeitig linke Augen getraint?
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass beide Augen getraint haben.
Aber wenn Sie Schmerzen haben?
Ja.
Könnten wir erst als gesprochen beginnen?
Ich habe eine neue Patientin, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Hatten Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Es geht um Herr Kaufmann.
Sie ist 29 Jahre alt, am 28.04.1989 geboren.
Er ist 39 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,73 m groß und 5,70 kg schwer.
Frau Inge Kaufmann hat sich heute wegen uns seit gestern Abend
plötzlich aufgetretene, persistierende,
sefalge Halbzeitige Links, sefalge Vorstellt.
Vorgestellt?
Ja, aber ich habe gegessen, dass die Kopfschmerzen
als rasend pulsierend und bohren Charakter haben.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 7 bis 8 von 10 auf eine Schmerzskala beurteilt.
Als Auslöser ist die Schmerzintensität aufgefallen.
Diese Schmerzintensität ist erstmalig.
Sie haben früher die Social-Beschwerden nicht gehabt.
Die Schmerzen sind erstmalig aufgetreten.
Früher hatte sie sowas nicht.
Wenn sie im Dunkelzimmer bleiben oder in der Ruhe im Bett bleiben,
hat sich die Schmerzinn verschlechtert.
Sie haben Fotofobie und Phonophobie.
Als Begleitzymptome klagte sie über Visusminderung.
Am Anfang von dieser Kopfschmerzin nur 20 Minuten gedauert haben.
20 Minuten lang hatte sie Sehstörung und danach haben die Kopfschmerzen angefangen.
Die Schmerzen sind nach 3 bis 4 Maligdegenerbrechen.
Am 1. Erbrechen sah sie aus wie die Nahrungserste.
Am Anfang oder die ganze Zeit hat sie sie immer noch gedauert.
Die Patienten haben 2 Mal 500 Milligramm Aspirin angenommen.
Aber nach dem Erbrechen haben sie sofort erbrochen.
Die Tablette hat keine Linderung herbeigeführt.
Logisch, wenn sie wieder aufschubt.
Die Erbrechen sind unabhängig bis auf Beschwerde bedingt und nur für gestern Schlafstörungen.
Die Erbrechen sind nicht so relevant.
Sie hatten nach 3 Jahren ein Kind geburt.
Sie haben eine Trombose in rechten Beinen aufgetreten.
Sie haben damals eine Ambulanz mit der Heparin und die Kompression Strumfe behandelt.
Sie haben nach der Heparin-Therapie eine Oralantikoglan eingeladen.
Im Bezug auf Medikamente nehmen sie nur beim Bedarf Aspirin.
Es sind keine allergenen Verträglichkeiten und durchgeführte Operationen bei ihr bekannt.
Die Nuxen an Amnesien sind unabhängig.
Sie machen Sport als nur am Wochenende Fahrradfahren.
Sie ist allein Erzieherin und hat 3 gesunde Kinder.
Als Beruf ist sie Marklerin und Anleichterin.
Sie haben viel Stress auf der Arbeit und im Privatleben.
Sie haben sich die Anleichterin in der Anleichterin geholfen.
Sie haben sich in der Anleichterin geholfen.
Alters, aber er hat Demenz und Mutter ist an cerebrale Tümur mit 660 verstorben.
Alle Anamnestischen Angaben dorthin am Ehesten auf eine Migren.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Betracht Meninge & Sepalitis und HWC, Hirntumor und Grüneshta-Krise im linken Auge.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Besonders werde ich die Karnich und Bulginski Zeichen machen wegen der Meninge & Sepalitis.
Ich habe schon die Patienten über die Narkensteiligkeit gefragt.
Sie wurde diese Frage verneint.
Wenn diese Zeichen positiv sind, werde ich auf eine Lumball-Punktion machen.
Als Labor bestimme ich Blutbild CIP, BSG.
Als Bildgebändes verfahren, werde ich MRT und CT eine Hirntumor oder suborachnoidal hemorrhagie auszuschließen.
Sie haben Angst wegen ihrer Mutter.
Was würden Sie mit der Patientin machen?
Sie können auf eine Lumball-Punktion verabreichen.
Was machen Sie gegen die Übelkeit?
Als Präventätier-Therapie können wir auch Beta-Blocher empfehlen.
Die Frau wartet bestimmt auf Sie.
Sind Sie so nett auf einem Laufenden, das mit Frau Kovermann weiter ist?
Dann hoffen wir, dass es ihr bald wieder besser geht.
Vielen Dank für die Zeit.
Mir ist aufgefallen, was wir beim letzten Mal aufgefallen haben.
Ich habe Ihnen gesagt, dass Sie immer eh dazwischen sagen.
Aber es war ein bisschen dramatisch.
Sie haben die Patientin immer schön mit Namen angesprochen.
Sie sind auf das eingegangen, nachher auf das, was sie Ihnen vorher gesagt hat.
Sie haben gesagt, ihre Mutter hatte einen Hirntumor.
Sie haben gezeigt, ich habe zugehört.
Ich habe mir das gemerkt.
Das war eine wichtige Information.
Ich habe mir auch ein paar Sachen mit dem Hirntumor geholfen.
Sie haben mir auch ein Schmerzmittel angeboten.
Sie haben alle entscheidenden Sachen erwähnt.
Auch in der entsprechenden Reihenfolge.
Das ist das Einzige, das bei Ihnen wirklich aufhält.
Ich kann das gar nicht so gut wiedergeben.
Aber Sie sagen, die Patientin nimmt keine Medikamente.
Das fällt wirklich auf.
Alle machen das ein bisschen.
Aber bei Ihnen ist es sehr krass.
Man merkt, dass Sie nach den richtigen Wörtern suchen.
Versuchen Sie das abzustellen.
Dann wird es ein bisschen eleganter.
Ein bisschen entspannter.
Aber es ist leichter gesagt, als getan.
Ich weiß das.
Rutsch!